VERSUS CONSERVATIVE SOLUTIONS.
THAT'S THE TOPIC OF TONIGHT IN
GOLD.
THE DHS SECRETARY KRISTIN
NIELSEN WAS INTERROGATED BY
SENATOR LORI BOOKER.
OVAL OFFICE MEETING, REFERRING
TO PEOPLE FROM AFRICAN COUNTRIES
AND HAITIANS WITH THE MOST
AND YOUR AMNESIA IS COMPLICIT.
THE PATTERN IS CLEAR OF THE
THREATS IN THAT COUNTRY.
I HURT.
FOR YOU NOT TO FEEL THAT HURT
AND THAT PAIN, AND TO DISMISS
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS OF MY
COLLEAGUES, THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE
TO ME.
>> Laura: HERE'S OF RAGE.
THAT'S ACTUALLY BAD ACTING.
GIVE ME A BREAK.
DID SENATOR BOOKER CRY TEARS OF
RAGE WHEN THIS STORY BROKE AND
HENCE HOME STATE OF NEW JERSEY
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO?
WERE AN ILLEGAL ALIEN BROKE INTO
A TRENTON HOME AND RAPED A
6-YEAR-OLD LITTLE GIRL.
WE LOOKED AND COULDN'T FIND A
SINGLE COMMENT BY SENATOR BOOKER
ABOUT THIS HEINOUS CRIME OF
UNSPEAKABLE CRUELTY.
DOES HE NOT FEEL THE HURT OF THE
CHILD'S MOTHER AND FATHER, A
CRIME THAT SHOULD HAVE NEVER
HAPPENED, BECAUSE THAT MAN
SHOULD HAVE NEVER BEEN IN THIS
COUNTRY, SENATOR.
HIS SILENCE IS UNACCEPTABLE AND
COMPLICIT, AT LEAST TO ME.
BOOKER IS SIMPLY OUT TESTING
CAMPAIGN THEMES.
IT'S PATENTLY OBVIOUS.
OPRAH HAD HER MOMENT AT THE
GOLDEN GLOBES, AND HE'S NOT
ABOUT TO SEE THAT SPOTLIGHT BACK
QUICKLY.
NO WAY.
HERE HE WAS BACK IN 2010, JOKING
AROUND WITH PRIVATE CITIZEN
TRUMP.
SEEMS PRETTY HAPPY TO BE SITTING
WITH A RACIST, DOESN'T HE?
BOOKER START TODAY WAS AN
ATTEMPT TO REINFORCE THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP AS A RACIST
NARRATIVE.
WE'VE BEEN SAYING ALL WEEK.
FOR BACKUP, FIVE LIBERAL
COMMERCE MEN AND WOMEN ARE
EXCHANGING
EXCHANGING THEIR HOME      -- WA
EXCHANGING THEIR HOME      -- WT
EXCHANGING THEIR HOME      -- WD
EXCHANGING THEIR HOME      -- WE
EXCHANGING THEIR HOME      -- WS
THAT ACCOMPLISH OTHER THAN MAYBE
GIVING THEM ANOTHER FREE NIGHT
TO BINGE WATCH ON NETFLIX?
SPEAKING OF WASTING TIME, THE
LEFT WING AMERICAN PRESS
WILLINGLY LINED UP TO DO WHAT
DEMOCRATS STORY LINE.
TO THEM, SLANDERING THE
PRESIDENT BEATS REPORTING ANY
TIME ON    ON THE ECONOMY.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS A WHITE
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS A RACIST.
>> WE HAVE A RACIST, A SHAMELESS
RACIST, WHO HAS HIJACKED THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, WHO HAS
HIJACKED THE OVAL OFFICE.
>> I WOULD SAY, JUDGING BY HIS
WORDS, A RACIST.
>> A HARD RAIN IS GOING TO FALL
ON DONALD TRUMP AND THE
REPUBLICAN SOON TO ENABLE THE
SORT OF RACISM.
>> Laura: SO TIRED.
IN A POSITIVELY BIZARRE SCENE
UNFOLDED AT THE PRESS BRIEFING
TODAY, MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA
ACTUALLY THINK THAT A MILITARY
DOCTOR IS PART OF THE
WHITE HOUSE SCHEME TO CONCEAL
THE PRESIDENT'S TRUE MENTAL
CONDITION FROM ALL OF US.
>> THERE ISN'T ANYTHING THAT'S
PART OF THE PRESIDENT'S HEALTH
RECORD OR PHYSICAL FITNESS OR
TELL US, IS THERE ANYTHING
YOU ON TRACK SCOPE THERE WERE
ENDLESS QUESTIONS ABOUT TRUMP'S
A DIET, HIS WORKOUT, GLUE TEEN
OR LACK THEREOF.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE THAT
ROUTINE?
YOU FIRST, SWEETHEART.
POINTED OUT THIS GEM.
>> SAYING A LOT OF SKEPTICISM OF
OVER THE IDEA THAT REAL
DONALD TRUMP WEIGHS ONLY
239 POUNDS.
WHAT HE STEPPED ON A SCALE IN
PUBLIC TO PROVE IT?
>> Laura: HE WILL DO THAT WHEN
REPORTERS AND ANCHORS AGREED TO
PUBLIC LIE DETECTOR TEST DURING
AS TRUMP'S TEAM IS RENEGOTIATING
NAFTA, BRING UP OUR ENERGY
SECTOR, SMASHING ISIS, CRACKING
DOWN ON MS-13, ALL THE REST, THE
DEMOCRATS AND A CANDLE OF
GLOBALIST NEVER TRUMPER'S ARE
MAKING COMPLETE AND TOTAL
BUFFOONS OF THEMSELVES.
IT'S ACTUAL EMPTY BACK ACTUALLY
EMBARRASSING NO SELF-RESPECT.
BECAUSE OF THE BLUSTER ON RACE,
WHAT WILL HAPPEN?
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT WILL HAPPEN.
MORE AMERICANS WILL END UP
TUNING THEM OUT, AND SADLY IN
THE PROCESS, TUNING OUT REAL
RACISM WHEN IT HAPPENS.
IMMIGRANTS AHEAD OF FUNDING THE
GOVERNMENT FOR AMERICAN
PARTY OF SOLUTION INSTEAD OF
STUNTS.
RONALD REAGAN ONCE SAID THAT
GOVERNMENTS HAVE A TENDENCY NOT
TO SOLVE PROBLEMS, ONLY TO
REARRANGE THEM.
EAGER TO CHANGE THAT SAD
REALITY, THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS ACTUALLY
WORKING TO EXPAND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL AMERICANS
AND ALSO SOLVE COMPLICATED
UP TO CHINA, AND IT'S MARRIED
ABOUT'S GROUP REAL, NAME ONE.
WHAT OTHER PRESIDENTS
WHAT OTHER PRESIDENTS          P
WHAT OTHER PRESIDENTS          E
WHAT OTHER PRESIDENTS          I
WHAT OTHER PRESIDENTS          T
WHAT OTHER PRESIDENTS          H
WHAT OTHER PRESIDENTS          S
WHAT OTHER PRESIDENTS          B
WHAT OTHER PRESIDENTS          O
WHAT OTHER PRESIDENTS          G
WHAT OTHER PRESIDENTS          T
CAPITAL AND MANUFACTURED BACK TO
TRUMP DIDN'T BELIEVE THEM.
THAT WILL BENEFIT WORKING-CLASS
AMERICANS?
INSTEAD OF JUST BENEFITING THE
WEALTHY.
ALL OF THOSE RICH PEOPLE THAT
WANT THE CHEAP LABOR.
HE IS DOING THIS AND ENDURING
CONSTANT, NONSTOP, UNFAIR NASTY
CRITICISM.
HE IS DOING IT FOR ONE SIMPLE
PEOPLE, PEOPLE OF ALL RACES, AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP CAN SOMETIMES
STEP ON HIS OWN GOOD NEWS,
SOMETIMES OF COURSE SAYING
NOTHING IS THE BEST THING, AND
MAYBE HE SHOULD ABIDE BY THAT
ONCE IN A WHILE.
HE'S ACTUALLY TRYING TO DO WITH
SO MANY POLITICIANS HAVE
PROMISED BUT COULD NOT DELIVER.